in our special series school matters
we're looking at the debates
over how to reopen schools safely during
the pandemic
this morning what it's like for freshmen
starting college
we hear from annie poole of washington
state who is attending barnard college
alejandro estadio of new york who
attends my alma mater georgetown
university go hoyas
californian harshita bachchina is at
california polytechnic state university
in san luis obispo
and wyatt george of massachusetts is at
virginia tech
it still feels really weird to say this
but i guess i
did graduate high school in the middle
of a pandemic
the pandemic definitely did its toll on
my class senior year it's i mean
it can easily be summed up by a couple
of highs and
one massive low at the time we thought
it was like an early spring break we
were all happy
but we finally got the email that we
wouldn't go back to school at all
i was actually supposed to have a calc
test that day
and to think that i was still stressing
out about that
is really actually crazy
i missed my high school prom my
graduation
my last pep rally and the one that hit
me the hardest was i missed my
last lacrosse season i was definitely
sad to not like
walk across the stage with my friends
but in the big perspective at least i'm
not like in the hospital fighting for my
life
i think the year got cut short right as
we were
beginning to maybe truly truly
appreciate
each other's presence it's a weird
time to be a senior it's a weird time to
be an incoming freshman
i get to register for my classes in
about an
hour it feels like i actually
am starting college a little bit and i
found out about a week ago that i will
still be heading to new york
in the fall i went on a road trip to san
luis obispo to just check out the campus
obviously there was nobody there and all
like the facilities were closed
definitely wasn't like the orientation i
was looking for but it was great i am
one of the lucky ones
i will be going away in about eight days
to virginia
but i would be lying to you if i said
everything was business as usual because
it's not
i had to do this extensive packing list
got the big bottle hand sanitizer though
had to get the lysol spray and had to
get those clorox wipes
i'm torn i'm trying to find ways that i
can kind of feel
positive about how things are gonna go
but i find it hard to
forget about all the things that we are
losing
[Music]
i found out about two days before i was
supposed to leave for new york
to start quarantining at barnard in
colombia
made the decision to go remote this
semester i feel like
my life has been flipped upside down
about like five different times in the
past week
i am definitely not excited to take a
coronavirus test rate the second i get
to school
which is gonna definitely be an
unpleasant experience from what i've
heard
i got my schedule and i realized all of
my classes were online
so then i was like wow i'm not gonna get
my freshman year experience either
i had wanted to show you all kind of
where
my internship took place but also where
my classes will this fall semester it is
my room in fact i never want to get the
virus
so at least being at home lowers that
risk but
it is frustrating why am i always the
one making decisions
my emotions about the future are very
mixed
i just got to new york the other day and
i'm moving
into an apartment with two other barnard
girls i'm really excited to finally be
independent
to be living on my own i reached out to
um
many kids on like facebook and instagram
and i met so many great people through
there that are
also going to slow and i've been getting
to know them
it's been really great it's just times
like these you just gotta appreciate
everything you have
and so never take anything in your life
for granted because you never know when
it could be stripped away from you let's
go
class of 2020 we're definitely the
strongest class
no matter what challenges come our way
we're always gonna face them head-on
everyone seems to be going out of their
way to meet others
um i think that's ultimately the best
thing that we can do is just trying to
make the best of our situations
i'm way more hopeful about how these
next few months are going to turn out
than i was even two weeks ago
so yeah i think that's a perfect way to
end it
[Music]
wow you really feel for these kids you
really do think of all the stuff
i like why georgia what you said we've
had a lot of stuff thrown at us yeah i
also like wyatt's blue
wig i like why george but just think
remember how excited we were to go to
college when you went you're looking
forward to this well for senior year of
high school and freshman year of college
doubly gypped and deprived getting
sheets and tells they got clorox
special shout out to eliana mentz who
was the one that put that together those
are very hard to do
eliana love your music choices we'll be
right back stay with us
we'll be right back
you're watching cbs this morning